so yeah like so we picked three episodes
for us each to watch that was
six episodes that we needed to watch in
a row yeah i i have never watched six
episodes of hentai
in a row in my [ __ ] i have never
watched six episodes of hentai in a row
and not jack off
it was super weird watching six episodes
and knowing that i have to watch them in
like an objective sense
like an analytical yeah man
i'm not gonna lie i'm saying i busted a
nut to one of them
in my head i was like some of these i
was like okay this is like
definitely like jack off material yeah
but
i it'd be really weird to just whip out
my dick being like this is the one that
got recommended
in the back of my mind the entire time
i'm not masturbating to god's thoughts
damn god did a good job on this game
that's hard i will say i feel like
closer to you boys after
after this because like you know like
you have a level of friendship where you
start recommending anime and shows for
each other to watch
i have never in my life recommended
hentai to watch for the boys and be like
yeah yeah the boys are gonna enjoy this
i'm looking forward to what they think
about what i like
i can't wait for the weekly discussion
of this it's just like a next level of
like bro ship and romance yeah okay so
we all chose
three each i was under the impression
that we were picking ones that we
thought were like our favorites so these
so the three you picked are your
favorites
no i mean okay okay the reason was that
i didn't want to pick ones that were
just like
we would all be like yeah that's good
[ __ ] yeah yeah because you know if
if i selected like masterpiece right
which in its name it's a masterpiece
yeah you can't hate on that right
maybe you could give me like a little
[ __ ] i mean it's it's
it's good it's good it's not it's not a
masterpiece i wouldn't call it it is a
masterpiece con i think
after seeing you're the three hentai
that you recommended
i can see why you would think it's a
masterpiece i was just like corner
recommended the three hentai and i
immediately was like
okay i know his taste i know kind of i
know what kind of man connor i i love
how like we gave each other like a list
right being like
joey's three bomb guns three bomb
connoisseur bomb i didn't even have to
see conor's name to know
i just read the titles and i'm like i
know okay i know exactly i know you
don't know exactly what connor is saying
yeah when you know joey recommends a
list right you know it's all three
japanese things i'm like [ __ ] knows what
that is
through japanese and what if mine just
has a porn english name and like
obviously
it's gonna it's gonna look better no not
even like the japanese titles i was like
yeah i don't understand what they mean i
was like i understand or i'll
i will i will elaborate yeah because
like i didn't pick my favorite ones
because i was the last one to share my
list
and it's okay when you have three hentai
to recommend it's [ __ ] hard selection
because like what did you go
for did you go for like funny ones or
did you go for ones that would be good
bands or would you go for like your
personal favorites have you noted to
each one on your list
i have yes yes i have two but i would
say but
i wouldn't say they're my favorite yeah
there's one i haven't nodded to which
was probably i don't know
exactly which one we'll get to that one
because it's just like how how do you
nut
this one but it's like yes i have nutted
to the rest of the ones on my list
but like i wouldn't say that they're my
favorites ones no
i thought the qualification was like
it's like one of those hentai where if
you put it on you're always not to it
i thought that was like well i
definitely i i definitely could not do
all three of mine yeah but they're not
my first choice that's what i'm saying
okay okay okay like because i didn't
okay so if i were to pick my actual
favorites it would be like a really
boring list true yeah that's what i
guess sometimes i'm trying
it would also be ones that like
everyone's probably heard of yeah
i didn't want to pick ones that are like
too famous that like everyone's heard of
it's hard because i wanted to pick some
but and then the ones that i wanted to
pick i'm like well
this is kind of sad it's going to make
me look pathetic
but i was like [ __ ] it i'll just choose
it [ __ ] it because which ones did you
actually want to pick then
if i would have a masterpiece would have
been on there okay the whole [ __ ]
series yeah man
there are some other ones like i think
uh what is it like oh is it joshi lucky
that one's pretty good
i love that one there's a few other ones
i can't remember that because i was the
problem as well because
i watched these hentai you think i
[ __ ] remember the name i'm like no
so i had to go through like all these
hentai images
like [ __ ] all right i think this
image is a good scene and then some of
them i would find and i'm like
i only like one scene and the other
three scenes are really [ __ ]
right yeah like gross yeah uh then
there's a few where it's just like and
if it has a lolly in it i'm immediately
like no right right i cannot like
yeah because like i would have
recommended like you know monkey to
happening or something but yeah yeah
everyone's already
everyone's watched everyone knows like
yeah the summer wars won over the [ __ ]
on the beach
with those girls resort
a lot of mine end up being like just
like wholesome vanilla ones and i'm just
like yeah
yeah yeah you know i'm just like this
this ain't gonna make it when vanilla's
done well it's just good man it's like
[ __ ] because like there's
plenty of like good vanilla hentai that
i want to
recommend but i'm just like we we're all
just gonna be sitting here being like
yes this is uh this is this is good
yes vanilla is also my favorite flavor
vanilla has its place
i do also like feeling wholesome when i
have a wanker every now and again you
know that that is my favorite what i'm
saying is right
yeah vanilla has its place don't get me
wrong but you know
what i want if there's a podcast episode
where we talk about ice cream flavors i
don't want to talk about vanilla for two
hours you know what i mean
exactly let's let's let's get the other
weirder flavors right because we're
gonna talk about it
we're not gonna talk about vanilla for
two hours but you know i'm like which is
why i'm glad
that when i saw joey's list his three
list
was like it your your your three that
you picked encompassed like half of the
things i wanted to like recommend yeah
yeah
i feel like yeah i feel like i figured
out joey's taste pretty quickly yeah as
well i mean like
i saw jerry's list and i'm like i know
what this guy wants to talk about
because i wanted to talk about the exact
same thing
but i'm like i'm glad you picked these
ones so i can pick other weirder ones
it's gonna be another episode where it's
like the two boys agree
i'm here like fighting the good fight in
the corner man yeah we got the hand-tied
monopoly man and steve hand jobs over
here
with this [ __ ] turtleneck oh my god